[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mike
check mike check what is going on lords
my man fozzie what's going on man
let me know how my levels are sounding
corey mosey what's going on
my journey gaming thinking about coming
back
let me know we about to see what bungie
got cooking man
he's doing it again let's do it again i
don't know what's going on with that
stream yeah
i don't know we'll probably have to
re-put the uh the the actual video in
there again
yeah so i'm going something weird
happening let me know if they can hear
me though
yeah i hear you i i checked in on this
yeah what's going on with the connection
man
so it's okay fuzzy said what up that's
good
dragon heart yo what's up man thank you
bro yeah
i don't know man youtube's always
something don't check the uh
stream rate going on
can't wait for me only yeah i'd be too
bro and so this is this is a weird one
because they kind of came out of nowhere
with this stream
and they're being very cryptic very
secretive
marion the mad what's going on man
chilling
[Music]
real quick okay
oh okay lord gave me that bit i see
[Music]
surprise stream
[Music]
what up what up what up how's it going
what's up what's up all the way
across the pond my man
that's [ __ ] helped me get the uh the
catalyst last night i was so happy i
didn't even get the credit in the tweet
yo you know what's funny i had it
written
and then i messed up your name
because you don't have death with the d
in the beginning
yeah no it's like oh and then when i
sent it i saw you
i felt so bad i'm like oh i forgot to
put my beard back in
i saw the tweet and i was like oh but yo
yo
yo listen your guardian is in there your
name is in there
you know what i'm saying all the dude is
from twitch what's going on
dude that's my guy bantering babble in
the house what's up man
but yeah my bad yeah we ran spy our
stars last night
i had to beg i had to bang these guys i
was like look
i've never got sleep with similar
catalyst i want to just run the first
part that's
it said i had to drag the whole crew
kicking and scratching forte complaining
death complaining about to go to bed
i wasn't complaining
now you i was complaining about you
complaining no i was complaining about
you because you got the last time we did
you got the catalyst and i know he don't
care about that catalyst like i do
so we run it you know i put on a
contender shell because sen set us up
he'll put on the container
maybe that increases your chances and we
did it and um
it was so funny as soon as the it kind
of ended and i go up and i see it drop
i screamed so loud it was like i got
gallahol for the first time
yeah man dracula yeah i didn't expect a
vidoc man
[Music]
dude making funny he said y'all
complaining about complaining i've come
to the right spot yeah man so let me
know chat which i think man
i mean no promo for this stream
normally the twab would end and we'd get
hey
tune in next week they're about to drop
us with
what you think i i think we about to get
one of those
okay i know we should have told you
before
oh it's got to be big and then if you
look at the community managers you got
the eyeball emojis
like i i think they'll just give you the
rending of what to expect over the
coming
months and maybe they just like like
maybe because it's been so crazy they
they they just forgot to promote
yeah they probably did i'm waiting the
dude said what i said on twitch he said
i'm trying to keep my expectations in
check but i feel like this is a height
building
announcement yeah maybe cross-play
announcement tease
yeah i i agree i think this i don't
normally get too
gassed and i usually keep my expertise
but the secretive nature of this and out
of nowhere
leads me to believe there's something
more than just hey here's the future
here's the state of destiny
you know here's what you're going to
expect kind of thing so
i don't know let's see i hope i'll be
pleasantly surprised
just waiting for forte to get up in a
building
i'm gonna need that memorial kiosk info
and if they hand that in for over
because they should
because they said they would then they
hand over that info
and everything looks good to me i'll be
so happy
erin kill what's going on is there
rumors that we're going back to the old
tower
once which because i popped in on mesa
because i saw him going live and i was
curious what he was reading and
he's reading some like by dog something
i don't know
it looked like he was on the bungee
website digital foundry got the uh
the playstation 5 man john lennon he
tweeted
10 minutes ago that thing's big bro
it's it's all right we don't even need
to buy guns anymore just by playstation
5. you can
you can do more damage for playstation 5
than you can shooting [ __ ] anymore
yes you'll pre-order that series x for
that sweet 60 frames
ah you got to wait you got to wait til
december 8th though for that for the
patch
just got to be clear
download the game december 8th watching
he said they showed the old tower in
promo images
interesting we know they're doing the
cosmic drone right we got the cosmic
drone going
because you you remember destiny 1 there
was that exotic
vendor person um crazy if we went back
remember in d1 there was that exotic
person
not like zero or anything but there was
a way you could get like
exotics that you didn't have before
yo they coming for king mexico physical
ps5
exists in the real existing real world
throw kick in the bushes
and light that bushel oh yeah he got a
whole lot he got a hole in
holding him uh i picked last week's
topic i was like yeah
media got it now what's up it's it's
it's it's definitely coming out yeah
he holds it on there what he said now he
said oh
it's they just saying it for the sake of
saying it and it's not really going to
be to the back
are you really sorry doing stuff like
that you might as well kiss your company
goodbye
like you hold it on shot the king to
hold it on
shut up oh my god
too funny all right so they supposed to
be on twitch
and they ain't live yet
we'll probably go live and say we have
10 minutes to wait to the streets
yeah and then they get the countdown and
yeah you know how they go
dude they've been killing with the
promos especially them trailers cursed
lit yeah i would love
if we went back to the old tower look on
the real yeah go yeah i did see that
rumor the traveler getting healed
brandon bryce what's going on man the
liz what's up
rca ps5k yo y'all savage savage
with that ps5 sign but um yeah man
we got that let me know what y'all think
about that new um vendor in the
cosmodrome which i'm thinking about that
i'm hearing aldrin rumors
which i'm thinking lonely songs with
alcohol
you they they they're going to you know
like i saw the um promos and stuff
foreign i'm like
okay so where are they gonna because the
story's gonna be fire
it looks like it's gonna be you know
we're going in a completely different
direction
but what happens if all everything we've
done for the traveler turns out we'd be
doing the wrong thing the traveler is
actually who we should be working for
that'd be the biggest mic drop you'll be
like wait a second
yeah that would be crazy that light
expansion is happening in
uh two years from now if if like
he's actually evil yeah right
it's all maybe they're both evil and
they're both two different sides of the
same coin
the dude out here was slander again i'm
so happy cognito said he was mating
hunter beginning with beyond light
so proud of him that is not happening
sir
i am down with the floof
do it i can't knock your jaw the titans
man
i can't i'm about that magic that's
space magic
[Music]
but i go in front though hunters i got
blank back and that that stasis power
looking serious titans looking serious
with that um
what is it that overshield now that you
get in the uh
yeah yo solo activities with the
overshield though
seriously yo being able to solo
something and just pop the overshield
differently
it's not even like the the solo actor
like imagine
imagine what it's going to be like to
chase someone around the corner chase
the titan around the corner
and then he pops an overshield well
that's the thing
it's
[Music]
here comes that dirty hunter talk and
i'm gonna shoot
a little bit to of time check your dm
brother get up in here
i'll hit you bro cause i mean this
dude dude if you're not at work let me
know cuz you need to get in here man you
have not done the last word we have not
done a podcast together in so long
dude we gotta we gotta link up brother
yeah we out here fraud and bro you gotta
get in here
it is it is definitely a it's definitely
a good old snap button
it's like oh i'm about to die i'm the
last one alive let me pop my super real
quick
yo hit on his screen with the joint
yeah i'll hit him get hit with the giant
hang on here you got to get up in here
all right somebody said and buying
followers no thank you we don't want to
buy followers
thank you thank you twitch we appreciate
you but no
let me refresh the bungie page
see what's going on oh you're in a zoom
call for work
oh you got okay okay i got you i got you
no doubt no doubt
yo but like i said we got it we got to
make something happen if evenings let me
know what worked out i know fridays is
tough i know you work what about
evenings
my lords again with that name the
building my man
how's how's a little lord kindly man
how's he doing man
good to see you up in here you're
getting ready for destiny you're getting
ready
my console brother's getting hyped
what's up man
took a minute for mr ultrawide oh you
are you flexing this is this is the
ocean ride
ultra wide oh because your body is so
wide like
it can't handle hey guys
that's the name of that's the pc side of
forte
ultra wide forte oh you've been playing
division macbook
don't you know that game is dead what's
going on with you
i know that ain't slow-mo i i hope it
was about the rope slow-mo ahead oh man
cause
yo yo yo bad solo was looking yo ubisoft
put out a whole list
of all the games every game they're
updating 4k 60
rainbow six siege 120 frames and
division is nowhere to be he tries to
disown that game now he's a bit oh no
that game's trash i don't play that game
it's like
the dude i'm gone fall i'm picking up
day one to do definitely
goes to stephen lemons yeah i'm in all
the way i just got to get two i've been
so busy
but yeah i'm a huge ghost to sushima
stan
it is what it is i love that game and
they doing raised i heard the um kai
boxer told me the pvp i mean the uh
pve is amazing he said division two
equals filed up the yeah we gotta
we gotta slander them man they was
talking strong you gotta kick them when
they down man
they were here when they down they were
calling themselves the destiny killer
they were feeling themselves they had
their first raid
they thought it was over for us and time
and time again what's the game that
still stands to test the time for tape
destiny what did my man what did that
what what was great
what game was that spewed on the live
stream with the iron lords the other day
i heard more i bet you i bet you i bet
you my co-host was throwing up in his
mouth
destiny yeah let me hear yo let me tell
your level screen talk to you talk to
the people
can you hear me there you go there you
go what's up brother
nothing this is a fun surprise yeah i
hit you because i'm like look
we're talking to the chat now am i out
of bounds for getting excited being that
they did not promote this vidoc
in any way they didn't give us a preview
of a vid
coming on uh on the end of a 12 and just
and now um
damage just on twitter he just put the
eyeball emojis like something about to
happen
[Music]
um i had heard like some wrestling about
possibly something but they didn't know
what it was
like some people were saying there might
be like a cut scene at the end of
um next week but
uh i hadn't heard anything about it
specifically so
um how we gonna get this dumb gun that
don't make any sense no more call
hawkmoon
we're gonna re-imagine hawkmoon i'm
gonna reinvest
the time is now guardian go get your
hands on the hawkmoon
with broken perks that don't break
anymore
i think bungie is slowly starting to
realize that they they can only do
they can do two things they can either
tell us something's gonna happen and
we'll be disappointed with it or they
can surprise us
they posted it on youtube but i don't
know if it's on twitch right now i don't
they don't look like they on twitch fan
let me check what's going on youtube
cause twitch look dead is the door now
i've been refreshing all this time well
twitch is dead is adorned
what is it under bungie.net or is it or
brother bucky
or is it on youtube i think they think
they stream theirs under
[Music]
once they said three minutes to do
what's like easy hey dude is that three
minutes
that you see on on this on their stream
it's under bungie it's under bungie oh
it's on the budget on youtube
on youtube
[Music]
i posted it in the uh destiny
i don't know man what the hell is a and
z man you got us going
what's what what is this
[Music]
also this isn't a stream oh this is
already pre-recorded then
yeah oh look just play it we could talk
so is done already
[Music]
there's only four views on it there's
only four all right so
it's just i'm gonna switch over give me
a second
and then we'll switch over
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys
[Music]
man what what country is this
beyond life kicks off trilogy of stories
where's the english speaking language at
legit this is it players are going to go
on a journey to discover the true nature
of the story
yeah yeah i'm hitting three of
players learning more about the darkness
and in fact going so far as to wield it
it's about leaving comfort and safety
behind walking a different road than one
that you may have believed you're
destined for
what makes something bad what makes
darkness
dark he said a little crease
down to his knees who was that he looked
like addict more
how are those learnings going to change
this is crazy you know over the last six
years
indicated guardians for the longest time
have been bathed in the light sort of
this altruistic force fighting back evil
and now we're starting to move into that
gray area between the light and dark if
the darkness reaches out
we must reach back i will not sex
in season the vanguard is divided you
have some characters telling you
you know we should fight these ships and
we have other characters who are saying
no no we should find out what they want
we should get to know them and
understand
more but it definitely comes to a head
this next year in destiny is really just
about how all the different characters
and factions are reacting to these
disappeared destinations and what that
means
as the pyramids have arrived in our
system not for the first time but for
the second time
we're going to see the return of a
character who's been absent for a pretty
long time in the stranger and
boy does she have a lot to say and she
has a lot
of time there might be you explain when
i know more
you'll know more she has shown up to
encourage
us to take on the darkness and
the only way to truly stop it is to work
with it and here comes our guardian
right on time seems like a very
story heavy this time which i like why
did the darkness
invite us here glad you're talking
europa is literally like a time capsule
europa is huge killer destination
freezing cold
desolate some of the most beautiful
spaces i've ever seen in the video game
there was a lot built on europa during
the golden age and
a lot of that was built underground
clovis spray
had some research facilities there
really pushing the limits of
technology and innovation there maybe
stepping into some things that
we shouldn't have under the eyes
all kinds of secrets i'm so excited for
what players are going to find
that music is knocking
up sky boxes bro look at that the storm
on europa was actually something we've
wanted to do for a long time
we wanted it to feel harsh the weather
system
is so awesome like you're walking
through
an open space and all of a sudden things
start happening
coming across like fallen or vex for the
first time
you can barely make out the glow in
their eyes
yo that's fire the sound of the wind the
ice will change based on what the
weather is looking like
you'll actually feel every piece of the
environment changing
around you to match the storm
europa itself is a pretty foreboding
place aramis is there in advance of us
and she set up a forward base
she has lieutenants who have gotten
their hands on
stasis gotten their hands on the
darkness and they're learning to wield
it
one by one we will
rise again and so i think her
motivations are really interesting too
today we begin breaking
free from our aramis
really challenges a lot of the ways that
we think about
light and darkness she's gonna make you
think about
your relationship with the traveler
she's a compelling leader and she has a
vision
and especially after the collapse of
their society
people i think the fallen wanted someone
to follow
is the light gonna be enough i think
we've seen
that we need some new tools to fight our
enemies with
maybe it's time to fight fire with fire
or ice with ice
[Music]
servicers ain't boss no more i see
stasis is
you know it's not just a lot of supers
but it's a new damage type
let's get it we've got solar void arc
and now we've got stasis
the idea for stasis all really came back
from the gameplay idea
of freezing someone that was kind of the
theme that everyone kind of rallied
behind you know dimas an amazing concept
artist had some images that really kind
of
put us on the right path what
really was landing with that was
cosmic ice that's kind of where the
cosmic comes in
once you freeze it solid i'm able to hit
him again and
shatter him in pieces the pieces break
apart and explode in those sharp
shards that can damage you so all that
kind of came together when we landed on
that team
okay hunters
stasis is gonna not only change the way
that you can attack or approach
combat there's also some really great
ways that you can upgrade it
then you start getting into like the
more interesting parts things that we're
calling aspects and fragments which are
additional ways to modify your subclass
aspects oh my rift is freezing let's go
and then the fragments are the things
that are class agnostic but depending on
what your class
is and depending what your aspects are
and how you want to play you're probably
going to be starting to
select different ones in there this is
just the beginning for stasis we're
going to continue to expand on it
we're just excited for players to get
their hands on this
when we're creating a new palette like
stasis we do what we call a source jam
everyone on the team blocks out about a
week
where we can say okay you're going to go
out into the world
microphone recorder record anything that
reminds you of cosmic ice
it says sub-zero will be a dlc that
gives us the palace
i found personally that the best way to
do it was
at night but doing scream screeches
and blood curdling yells is a little
scary at night then
i had a really rumbly stomach and that
also
was recorded there was also a breast
pump
wow they basically meant to say go out
into the world and just make weird
noises
that's cool you have to make these guys
what you got because how do you know
what cosmic
sounds like that's a good point
exotic weapons for you
no time to explain it's coming back
instead of just being the gun that
refills your magazines
you actually get a little time coil
you can actually have that on top of the
ark soul so you can be your own little
mini firing spot and build for it
oh i like we have the laments it uses up
your sword's energy to
give yourself a new combo that ends up i
wonder if that's going to be the season
pass
probably the largest selling point for a
lot of no actually you get it for
pre-ordering so it's not going to be the
season pass gun
i think the largest draw for most people
is going to be the fact that it is a
chainsaw sword
maybe yes
for beyond light we really wanted to
create exotic armor pieces
that formed a key part of your build
around which all the other parts of your
build could revolve
for example the titan gets the ice fall
mantle which
is a set of exotic arms that looks like
it is crafted
from golden age tech when you activate
you sort of
slam your arms down create a burst of
stasis energy
and then you cover yourself in an
overshield
the warlock exotic is necrotic grip grip
let's go
if you are facing a wave of thralls
running at you
you can nail them with your melee attack
and it starts to burst and sort of
cascade
through the whole group
that's crazy oh i'm gonna have a lot of
fun with that
don't be hating on the wall for
newcomers coming in too if you've got a
friend who
hasn't tried it out it's a really great
time to jump in on new life that entry
experience for free players
last year when new light launched we
brought back a small portion of the
cosmodrome
this year we're bringing back a much
larger portion of the destination
it takes some of the experiences that
started with original destiny 1
but puts them and stitches them together
in a different way and
adds new things and tells it a different
story
what you're going to meet in this new
opening experience that's the gallagher
is a character with not
one but two names for fast and the
furious
shahan thank the light i don't get these
people excited
what i love about the cosmodrome is it
feels like
destiny distilled
they showed his basket that is not
aldrin
oh but i want the original arrivals left
off
other forces are taking advantage of the
darkness
to make their move forward
including zebul rath a sister of oryx
and she's taking this opportunity to
build hunters
and we're working with osiris stop her
the guard is here
cyrus goes out in the bush across these
hive growths
that are driving combatants crazy
oh they hit the guard cyrus is in
trouble and of course you're his only
hope
what the hell is that oh the god is here
let's go
oh wait till i get to this part fire we
warned you it was going to be dangerous
down here
impossible oh it's on
wait till y'all get to that part
we finally catch up to what we saw at
the end of forsaken
where we saw aldrin being brought back
to life by a ghost
aldrin who now
the slate's been wiped clean when he was
resurrected
as a guardian we know what he's done
and he wouldn't notice him capable of
doing oh cyrus
how we look at ourselves how we look at
the light how we look at darkness
in season of the hunt we're partnering
with the crow and osiris to take down
the high celebrant
it's creating these crypto lifts around
the system and those crypto
are attracting elixir and cabal and
corrupting them
so zebu iraq is essentially corrupting
herself an army and it's our job
to put a stop to it i'm really excited
to see
zebra wrath fleshed out more and to find
out more about her relationship with
sabathune
and what that means for year four of
destinies sabathune has been
placing dominoes and at the end of year
four
she's gonna knock down the dominoes
we're gonna see what she's been really
up to
and so told you we were going back this
year she's putting the last pieces in
place
[Music]
well yeah all the leaks from years ago
were true i am like destiny is
just a really incredible world
and there are so many stories for us to
tell
we have a lot to look forward to beyond
light then the witch queen then
lightfall
and all the seasonal content between we
feel like we've got a really great way
to bring people together
working through covet and working
through some of the other turmoil in the
world right now has been really
challenging
surprised with how well we've been able
to get things done
we're committed to your characters and
your community of players
we want to meet you where you are
i think the thing that excites me the
most about destiny's future is how much
it's rooted
and where we come from i just realized
slumbo's in the building
seeing feelings revealed and finding out
secrets that
you got to come here because you know
division gives you no content
that gets me super excited
destiny's best days are ahead of us
let's go let's get it
luke smith with those jordans on as
usual
oh you hear that best days ahead of us
days ahead
brother i don't know about the rest of
these games
i don't know about the other looting
shooters
but i know who the king is was
that was great but what i really enjoyed
the most was osiris going
sort of cyrus
he would have beat him your man is in
the house all right
let's let's get that out of the way your
men ain't coming outside to deal with
the threats that my man is warning it's
about being deal with the real threats
your man stays at home and guards my
trials
don't do your job and guard try
anyway look a little fun bro i need to
speak to attic first
oh go let's gotta go there sir
oh he's still listening what are you
doing he muted yeah how far back
back is he i think i hear his stream
he's in the bushes
we wait for him to come back man but
forte let's get it bro
yo man so look man we already know
bungie know how to cut
a trailer and this defensive and this
wasn't even the trailer this is like a
well-crafted vinyl for them to spew
all the messaging they want everybody to
know about destiny
they want to get all their disciples
into the same room and say
all hell the altar that bungie put out
in front of us
but guess what but guess what though bro
let's let's be for real though let's get
it
bungie knows what they do they know they
have a they know they have a passionate
fan base that's
hungry for content as always and
and this looks and this looks good the
only thing
is i still i mean yeah i i know
we know audrey is a part of this story
now that's why we thought we
we know he's finally back in the story
eddie's dying
hans whatever his face yeah he's he's
he's named he's crow now so he don't
even know who he used to be
so the fact that we're still it's kind
of crazy that he's with us
yeah it's crazy he's always sorry but
the biggest thing is you know it just
seems like they're trying to like
loose miss it earlier this year they
want to tie up some of the loose ends
that they had festering throughout this
story
because it just seemed like year from
year to year we were starting
we were starting something new without
finishing anything
throughout this whole i think the last
time we finished the actual fight
was in destiny 1 when we took out
freaking uh
oryx is the last time we actually did
something from beginning to end
let me ask you one question yeah when
the
what was the thing osiris of some hive
growths that were oh
oryx's cyst like what was that they said
i didn't catch
anybody she's cur she's corrupting
anyone she can get her hands yeah she's
corrupting everyone
who is this new person or sister we
don't know we just
we literally just got well it's supposed
to be his sister
right that's what i'm like so this
entity seems separate
yeah they're talking about but they're i
mean that's i guess that's the
ambiguous part of it they're leaving
that part to you thinking they said
everything
you know she's moving chess piece right
now for her ultimate goal that will be
revealed throughout this year
so they're they're they're really
setting us up for them
is his other sister yeah all right
yeah he has two sisters i mean he had
more he had more sisters than that you
know until
he had daughters and everything we
didn't kill daughters we didn't kill him
we killed him we got a sister on the
block and we we we're going to take our
both siblings at the same time
i mean i mean i think that's what it's
going to be about look man i'm excited
for it the biggest thing is it just let
me address
go ahead yeah yeah
saying lord this cycle never ends yes uh
bungie drops the trailer destiny fans
swan uh
expansions drop destiny fans are
disappointed but
uh won't hold bungie accountable by
stopping no no
and supporting
listen the difference here slow-mo is
the fact that
it's not that we're disappointed we're
never really disappointed in what budgie
gives us
we're disappointed that we as players
want them to give us more we want so
much more because we play this game so
much
now is that fair of us to ask that of
bungie to say
yo we put 40 50 hours into this game
a month we want to get more content but
isn't it
didn't he play didn't he play the
division
this man from a dead game like is he
isn't his game a corpse
what game is it what happened to
borderland every game he puts
games that he's playing but he finds
himself in destiny streams
every time hold up let me talk to
something let me have a
good slow mo moment you got to the uh
outer wilds whatever the hell that game
is called
what is that game called well out of
worlds no this is the game
out writers outriders outright you got
that [ __ ] so you hopefully that might be
the thing that you can get you away from
being in here watching
the content uh then you you know you you
got you
god hand or god foreign
i don't know what the godfather so you
know maybe that could get you away from
uh hating in a destiny reaction screen
uh so i mean clearly i mean it's 10
o'clock in the morning you're in here
watching us watch a destiny trailer
so clearly they're doing something right
let's not let's not let slo-mo take our
joy right now
you see your way of ignoring the pain
he's out of control apparently
apparently we're not the only ones
ignoring these games
because they're dead as hell shout out
to slow for being messy he's always
messing you love it
but look forte man like i was saying
pretty sure there's more people in my
apartment than just playing the division
right now
oh my god look look let's let's close it
up man
i think it's i think it's good i think
it's amazing i just think right as of
right now the biggest thing is what are
what is the pipeline going to look like
a month after launch
we know we this is always the issue when
it comes to like with bungie we're
excited for
the offerings that are coming day one
but being
players that are super invested in the
game we're gonna blow through this
content and maybe this is a good thing
for this year because
the fact that we got new systems coming
out there's a bunch of games coming out
the fact that we are people that are
going to run through this content real
fast
it might be for the best for us because
we will have other things to go out and
actually play but i'm just hoping that
it's gonna we're gonna run through fast
though based on we could well
the rumors but you know damn while we're
running dude the rumors are savages
well wait that's what i'm saying well
see i'm only talking about me
people like there's people like slo-mo
that probably would take 10 years to get
through this
he don't know how to stick with one
thing he likes to jump around if it
ain't rolled
up he ain't playing it longer than 10
minutes oh my god
you know but but overall the biggest
thing that people got to realize is
it's all about what you want as a as a
player
you know it's going to overall it's
going to take me probably
two weeks three weeks even if this on
the long
end to is like forsaken levels of
lymph because it looks like they're
trying to go through that model with the
lieutenants and everything because
you're definitely going to have to go
through those lieutenants oh yeah she'll
get the air of this
so you know so we're going to pretty
much be doing the bearing thing
all over again yeah yeah i felt like the
barons yes that felt like the battery
yeah we're good we're doing that all
over again so if you want to take that
and say
they're basically padding the story with
that yeah let's be for real
the baron fights the the the lost set
not the losses but the adventures
yeah and that were some of the best
things they ever did in forsaken
so i will take more of that please but
what are we going to be doing after that
that's the question i'm gonna get to
that one i got an answer for you on that
but let me get a super chat shout out to
liz 22 to follow us from the chat
slow-mo
if you're my destiny addiction counselor
then let me book my appointments now
every day one hour blocks starting
november 10th
ah let's get it let's let's go let's go
oh
slovo is hanging he said road companies
greater than destiny
he said the liz my rates are two hundred
dollars an hour but i'll make sure
you'll have a better outlook on life
moving along let's get my man yeah
you need to stay away from slo-mo he
might try to get you to play the
division
and to me i'd rather i'd rather choose
death
choose choose whatever poison fits your
personality
and go out like a soldier that has not
played the division behave
what did you think about this uh beyond
like vidoc sir
they didn't really do much for me
[Music]
it's not this look why i i understand
that they have to
show the expansion they have to show the
new season that's going on after the
expansion
but i'm just like wait what new season
after the expansion what do you mean
yeah season of the hunt is after this
expansion that's when it starts the new
expansion
right and i'm just like
well season season of the hunt is the
expansion
yes i see until it comes out i'm gonna
see it just how they did forsaken where
forsaken is that
the core mechanic and then after that
they started building that whack ass
portal
like that wasn't forsaken sir
that definitely wasn't that was not for
shaking
you know it's just like the seasons are
so
i don't know like it's cool that old
john showed up but
it's just like they kind of made it seem
like he's not going to be in the
expansion he's going to be in the season
it's just getting now you acting like
they're telling us about something the
expansion of the season is the same
thing
this is not a future thing we're getting
this now
shadow keep wasn't like that you the
when the season started is after the
core gameplay was done with the
expansion shadow key
no it started at the same time
you just really didn't engage with the
season stuff until you were done with
the expansion
forgive attic it's easy to get these
trash storylines confused he's stupid
you're going in on it
just the way they were talking all i see
is us doing a public event
for two or three months building some
type of
resistance to whatever plague that works
or family got going on right now and
then some public
showdown at the end showing them
destroying it
like that's what it looked like to me
like that's what they're gonna start
building back up is another public event
let's be rare we did a public event or
some type of event
for like that
i'm just confused like did i watch the
same thing you watched i mean you could
be disappointed
i'm not i'm not hating on that but i'm
just saying like i didn't see i didn't i
didn't
see that i didn't see a future season i
don't know what was going on
you know they said that they they said
that the the season of the hunt
starts with odron
and uh what with um what's his name what
though sire is saying that some
what sabbath and whatever whatever
sister
he's doing see to to me that seems like
a different storyline
than you go into to the frost plant
whatever the [ __ ] that place is called
so you're thinking this is so separate
you're right i'm telling you i tell what
it's going to be is we're going to have
our
base game with shadow key
and that shadow keep beyond yeah i'm
half asleep yes
after you finish all of that and then
the raid then after that
is when the season of the hunt will
start
because for to me you know what's your
opinion we
we have we have all this buildup to be
on the light to
to going where the where the um exos
were made
to finding out what the darkness has
under the eyes and then they're like
and then like yo something else is
happening over here with those sires i'm
just like
i'm just like can we please finish
beyond light first like
that's what they always do they
literally do they did this thing
before they literally did the same thing
we we thought the whole game was going
to be about avenging cade
fighting the barons dealing with ultra
and that would be it
and then the whole storyline opened up
about this whole secret storyline that
wasn't promoted really
was about the dreaming city the cycle
and the curse and the courage
so you don't like extra content after
the initial cut i'm just confused i mean
you're right
it's your right to be disappointed i'm
not gonna argue with you guys you guys
no no wait what what not i i just you
know
two stories that you know never mind i'm
not gonna
have this conversation it's just like
you guys can be you
you that's cool
[Music]
it's okay bro no one forcing you to like
it if you don't like it it's cool
let's get let's get uh let's get that
for man that's man where you at
all right so it's looking good
i want to see where the story goes the
fact they're covering the other sister
that has
hardly any law about it's always the one
but the other side is intriguing because
the other sister really isn't as
malevolent as the other two as in she's
evil but she doesn't
really actively quite and want to
destroy everything she more just chills
in the background like oh just let these
two go on so
that's an interesting dynamic because
she doesn't like sarah thune anyway so
it's that's somehow gonna connect
um it's cool and then the whole you know
plant looks good me i
can't wait just get get that story
because i want to see how aldrin fits
into this with zavala
and then osiris
and then that whole thing and then like
just
generally exploit europa looks cool
because with the new
abilities now we might be able to get to
places
we technically shouldn't be going
with those abilities yes especially yes
big time
yeah like there might be places where
you know it isn't exactly on the beam
path um
but overall looking good everything is
looking in place i just want to get the
story in my hands
seek to see where we're going in the
future because we're going in a
direction
hopefully they get the story right they
need to actually
craft a story that's cohesive i agree
that
follows a good cadence where leads into
the next thing the seasons make sense
and shout out to my name is wife because
he dropped the road map
you just dropped it yeah he just dropped
the road map for beyond light
right now seriously i i dropped in with
this good that's the discord and
twitter yeah oh yeah we got a little
tasty roadmap
yo and it's looking interesting because
this answers question right here right
here let me see if i can blow this
up as best i can y'all so
looking at it right now um beyond like
campaign begin stasis unlocks
uh titan behemoth warlock shadebringer
hunter revenant
sabbath salvation's grip exotic we got
the exactly know about that okay so free
to all players
new destination europa new cosmonaut
experience which we've seen with the new
guy who is not older
um new season armor an exotic record new
strike at it so only one looks like
new law sectors plural 100 plus seasonal
ranks
new artifact mods new triumph shaders
and emblems iron banner and the dawning
so 11
10 that's when we start off we get the
artifact the reward the empire hunts
begin so that's what it's called empire
hunts
the glassway strike opens then from that
november 10th to all the way
to january 12th we have uncover europa's
secrets
november 13th adept weapons added to
trial so trials is starting right on
cadence right it looks like
it's starting right it's starting out
here let's start right on cadence
and then we got november 17th season
mission begins
and rathborn hunts begin what the hell
is that
of november 21st we know for a fact the
red oh deep stone [ __ ] is officially
looks like the name of the raid
deep stone [ __ ] so we're going away to
exo's on november 21st uh december 8th
is the first iron banner
and then december 15th through january
5th is the dawning returns
and then they say and more so exotic
weapons and homies not hawk moon cloud
strike no time to explain duality
salvation's grip
lament ice full mantle mask of back risk
actress and based on chorus necrotic
grip and precious scars
it's a lot a lot going on so the
question the one thing i will say in
addict's defense is
look at november 17th season missions
begin and that rathborn hunts begin
that's the public event oh you know what
that's going most likely yeah that's
definitely going to work like it could
be a public community
yeah it definitely sounds like it's a
public man there's no doubt about that
that's but
but if you look at rap isn't that the
dreaming city they're going to give us
some whack ass [ __ ] to do that whole
time with that yeah that is
that's the dreaming city in the back
yeah yeah
yeah vindicated yeah well you're not
vindicated tomorrow
i'm happy that um it'll be so right
about it we get it
we gotta strike though i am happy with
you
all right so uh scream man you're up man
now we got more information
where you at with what you saw the vidoc
and all this stuff
yeah i think it looks i i'm pretty
excited about all of it um
i thought we'd be going back to the
dreaming city simply because they
weren't getting rid of the dreaming city
yeah that's a good point yeah
so you know i'm i think it's gonna be
he's right it will be like a public
event style thing but it'll be very
like the thing about this like when you
get a
dlc right that's that's obviously
like your activities are really based
within that the seasons are
purely really meant i mean you get an
activity obviously but they're really
meant to drive the narrative like
that's what all the seasons do right and
you don't always get
i mean it's not always a public event
like remember um
when uh shadow keep released we got that
um
like the vex portals it was very similar
reminiscent to
the actual raid yes so
you know like i think well we'll see
when are we when's the raid actually
releasing the 21st so it's not the
the first saturday after release it's
the following sunday giving us a week to
prep for the raid
okay because sometimes i mean sometimes
you'll get a public event or an activity
that's reminiscent of
certain raid mechanics in certain ways
you know so maybe
that's an idea although deep stone crypt
is going to be on uh
europa yeah that's definitely wrong yeah
a little different
um yeah i
i mean the thing that really excited me
most about the trailer was just
all sort of the the plot points yes
and i it's like i i figured osiris was
not done i
thought i was surprised you see him to
be honest i didn't think we'd see him
i was surprised to get knocked on his
butt we're not going to talk about it
that was surprising
not knocking on the ground guardians
don't drop their guns continue
like in in my view the vex
like the vex are of of all the guardians
that we know of the vex are most heavily
tied
to osiris like he's sort of like that
guy
and um i think that they're gonna even
though we didn't see them in this
trailer
they're so heavily tied to what i think
our ultimate enemy
is right that you're going to need
somebody who sort of speaks that
language
but he's in fact he's investigating high
that's what surprised me
that's my thing though the vex and the
hive are together in this case the
darkness is a combo of those two things
it's like that's right that's why i knew
we would need them eventually in fact i
was surprised that we hadn't seen
like when we first got revealed of like
the three
the stranger yeah i thought he would be
you're right i thought he would be part
of the quartet
yeah of the you know the unlikely
frenemies that
are really yeah the kind of road guys
that are working together
so that actually threw me off when he
wasn't in that group because i thought
that was going to be
you know it was going to be the drifter
it was going to be uh
heiress and it was going to be him but
him coming back
i think uh plays into that ultimate goal
of like
the darkness is something have it's some
sort of
amalgamation of vex and and hive
but that's you know that's kind of again
tinfoil hat yeah
uh i think what we're getting right off
the
the rip is good and though we
all everybody in this group is probably
going to clear most of the
um most of the content or at least have
gotten into all of the content within
the first
week or two yeah um i'm going to be
spending a lot of time breaking the
cosmic drone again
the new glitch videos on wilhelm youtube
channel this spot right there
the spot 100 you want to find some stuff
that you're not supposed to be able to
do
it's going to be there because they're
bringing back some old stuff and all
those little things are going to
let me get this super chat real quick
i'm going to let you go nobody okay i'll
find out super chat mr weekend one but
shout out to the lords of the goat
khabib
man is truly an inspiration any remix
from playstation to xbox era you want i
want bulletproof yes khabib was amazing
man it's a ton of remakes man what have
i been getting so many
i could be all day stitch final super
chat in the words of the prophet king
david
game pass baby oh yeah that's a fact
that's a fact let me ask you this though
scream before i get back to you um
yeah this part that this guy tweeted
this really had me doing
this emoji right here cabal you got
osiris
zavala and tuka what's going on
told you cabal was going to be friends
with us too i
i when i saw that cinematic that had me
like yo
what is happening here and zavala is he
i mean is so sorry is this the top
like he don't really deal with vanguard
like this is different man
this is the split so in the lore
the leviathan was the guardian of the
worms that's in the lore
when they broke the leviathan chased
them
that's the cabal they're not i've never
thought that they were our pure enemies
i think the fact that kallus was always
kind of like
you know he kind of gave us stuff there
was never we never actually saw
kallus it was always kind of more like a
test rather than
like we're trying to defeat you that's
another thing they they
they better have a good reason why like
when i start beyond light there better
be some kind of lore
showing why that's not in our solar
system anymore like if i start that
campaign it's just gone
i think the rumor is there's supposed to
be
so i don't know if you heard this forte
there's supposed to be some season
ending event and that's cool i i want
more stuff like that
yeah so but i don't know a similar kind
of like the hobby when almighty crashed
into
you know i don't know if it's going to
go exactly that type of procedural thing
but the rumor is there is some
event at the end of this season that's
supposed to be i guess cataclysm
this season and saint 14 season
if they take the ideals that those
seasons brought up
and they really nurture them i think the
seasons can be good too
like i mean it lets me roll this none of
the seasons besides maybe two were trash
trash it's just they were underwhelming
because there was nothing to do right
but the thing i want to say to you is
this is
the in fairness to the expansion the
expansion is always
hit though like you're talking post
expansion
after that next december drop
those are the ones you usually
disappointed with because those are the
ones that don't
have all that oh no no i'm not i'm not
talking about beyond light i'm talking
about
that's why i said the season of the hunt
is after beyond life
and in that picture he showed us it is
after after it's not they're not the
same
but it said in that thing it's just
beyond light and it says up there beyond
light and season of the hunt calendar
but yeah season of the hunt is within
beyond light right
it's the two different things it's like
you'll get the it's like when we had
we literally have a beyond light
calendar right right
does not start in this yeah look at the
top november look
november through february it's in the
same day it's the online is this is the
season of the hunt
the season of the yeah when you see
seasonal artifact that means that you're
within a season yeah the reason
artifacts change so this is the first
one
beyond light ends and then it's the next
season
it's like when we got what was the very
first season in shadow keep i can't
remember it was when we had the vex
portals
um seasonal undying he's going to be on
dying yeah
launched the exact same time it was just
like most people played
all the shadow keep content that was
kind of like you had to kind of do all
the shadow keep content at least the
beginning game content before you kind
of went into that stuff
but it was all there at the exact same
time like we got
like shadow keep had the nightmare hunts
it had the moon and then
uh the stuff that was taking place on
the moon like the vex mine hearing
this comment disrespectful girlfriend
def sega don't laugh
he said i love how our guardian is
sitting there watching as a knight is
about to kill us
hey man i mean
running around with his space magic and
then
you know what um
what if the end game event is literally
literally like the leviathan
trying to swallow one of the pyramid
ships and then just getting destroyed
hmm like that's not gonna happen
completely
you might as well go yeah
the leviathan is not getting destroyed
it's going to leave
what happens what who's going to call it
back
yeah god who's going to call it [ __ ]
it's still alive
do you really do you realize in the lord
does callous not worship the darkness no
he doesn't worship he does it
no callus is probably the leviathan
itself like that thing is probably one
giant living thing and that's probably
who he is it's just
right he's probably a speaker that you
hear inside of it every time you run
through it
you know what you know what i'm really
hoping though is a mission where
you know the cabal come down and they
drop pods and help us beat some like
the reason the reason that the cabal
were against us at any point
wasn't really uh was more because they
felt that they were the people that
could defeat the darkness and it was
given to us
so they were resentful because the
the traveler didn't give them any power
that was like the whole part of
you know d2 the whole like them trying
to get the power of the light so that
they
could defeat the darkness in my opinion
because in the lore
the leviathan is at odds
they actually say the new the name
leviathan is at odds
with the worm gods that's in the lore
it's a logo before the worm gods
infected the proto-hive
that's it was like defer to you brother
um so i'll be just
a conclusion for you scream like overall
now that you've seen all this now we're
getting more information
how's your hype level wait where you at
man it's double what it was in shadow
keep and i thought shadow keep was the
best
dlc we ever had so wait you had shadows
that's god's word well actually i guess
the dreaming city was
i guess i guess most people would say
forsaken because the raid was so much
better
but um in my opinion like shadow keep
this had the most like i felt like we
learned the most throughout shadow keep
about like where we were going
because they really played the seasons
into the lore wise
lore wise yeah okay okay be clear be
clear
shadow keeps the best because his
channel grew the biggest off shadow
it was like a kill wall type thing and i
forgot about it but apart from that i
mean
yeah man i got it it took me like 10
minutes
let me go in look i was surprised here
because
obviously i spoke to e about this last
time
i knew aramis was not the end-all be-all
right no i knew i knew that was a that's
what we call
a sub boss back in the day right before
you but that's the sub boss
all right i love the story like where
they're going where it through me though
like i said
didn't expect to see didn't expect
evidence by osiris
but the thing that show it's like all
these different enemies and
friends working together like i said
that zavala
picture really resonated with me because
when i seen
i didn't even know osiris was there to
be honest i just saw him and two cabal
so i'm like okay
everybody's looks like they're deciding
to figure out
are the pyramids friendship would be
fighting them
they they pulled up oh yo let's let's
hear them out i like that aspect
so it looks like all the factions
there's a divide we see with the fallen
doing
they were like yo we rolling the
traveler didn't rock with us we going
over there
but it's cool to see different fractures
on different sides
i thought that was dope i liked that
fighting scene in the beginning
with the unholy trio with aerys the
stranger and the drifter getting busy
on europa i thought that was cool i
think this surprised me with how much
narrative is in this like i didn't think
we were gonna get
all these story beats now the only thing
i will worry in slow-mo's defense
in addict's defense is they are
adding a lot of characters it almost
feels like a lot of threads is all
in this right now it's their job to make
this
joint cohesive you know what i'm saying
because there's a lot like aldrin's
coming back
immediately right i was like okay go
when i seen him that to me that made the
experience i didn't care
when i seen aldrin come out that was
huge what you gonna say
do you think he's gonna be in vanilla uh
beyond light who
aldrin mm-hmm oh for sure
oh he's definitely what this is but
vanilla beyond light is season of the
hunt yeah you're getting confused like
you acting like caesar the hunt is some
separate thing that comes after
beyond light it's the same thing beyond
the night
the right and everything before we see
him come out oh you talk about when
okay it's still part of season of the
hunt
yeah you're acting like it's it's all
this is all one thing
season at a time all of this see like i
i mean you didn't know about
it like we didn't know about uh riven
until after we beat
the until this forsaken storyline was
over right you're gonna see alderan
on the 17th that's when you're gonna see
him right before the raid
like the narrative is going in a
direction where
now we are we're gonna depending on how
the campaign goes
we may have to eventually pick aside
yeah because the darkness
invited us to europe so they're like you
come
see the truth traveler is essentially
yeah
so when we find out what the truth of
the traveler is
what exactly is that because we really
don't know what the traveler is
in its totality and the spoiler the
spoiler is the traveler has healed right
because you've seen
i don't know if you saw that definitely
okay okay cool yeah so
the traveler so like he's because if
they turn around as you know it's
like oh by the way pick a side right
will you stick with the traveler will
you go with the darkness
that might be an option they throw in
there and be like yo who are you gonna
pick
and maybe that's why the characters are
split because some of them
arise thick loves the darkness she wants
to reach out and talk to him right
you saw that in shadow keep mm-hmm she
actually wants to
zavala's completely against yeah he's
against it he saw that in that yeah in
this video
so it's gonna be like one side
is gonna be for the darkness what's
gonna be against and i think he'll
eventually come to a point where we'll
have to choose
and i think that they alluded to that
also with light for all the future
expansion stuff like that the thing to
me that's exciting to me
like i said it seems very narrative
based i love that aspect i know we're
only getting one strike so i'm like
with that a lot of looks like there's
gonna be a lot of secrets i like that
part from
november 10th all the way to january we
got that rathborn i got to know what
that is because that involves the dream
of city and i i feel
aldrin stuff probably is going to pick
up then i agree with attic it'll
probably pick you up after the raid
let's not sleep on the deep stone crypt
you know i think we're going to learn a
lot with that
like i think that's going to be fine i
think we're going to get some story
beats there
hopefully they build up what the threat
is there but i think it's a lot of
content the key to them is just
again tying the loose ends and pushing
the story forward but what's cool is
they are bringing loose ends that people
were mad about
into this you know what i'm saying and
that part is cool so
that's why so so so for me to tie it up
let's get it
the reason i'm okay the reason i'm
excited for this isn't really even
because of what they show it's only it's
honestly because of last night i'm gonna
tell you
last night playing with you guys the
fact that we went into a raid
that is super irrelevant that's
nothing to do with anything that we're
doing with going forward
doing whisper the whisper missing doing
zero hour has no pr it has
nothing to do with anything that's going
on with the game going forward
the fact that you can still when you do
that stuff and you can still have that
much fun oh absolutely
playing outdated content just to help
people get stuff in the game
that they don't have is why i'm super
excited for what's coming up in this
next dlc because all it's going to do
is refill that funnel i know slo-mo's
talking next [ __ ]
correct he said he's excited about what
we got
in four he he mad that he mad that um
that rose company
is like literally making you pay for
every damn thing now you know at least
bungie willing to give us stuff insane
don't let them steal your joy brother no
but for real though listen
the fact that we were the fact that we
enjoyed that game so much
yesterday and playing with each other
that's what destiny is
we're getting more of what destiny is
and we're going to be able to chase
after this stuff
for a whole nother year and the thing is
before we didn't even know what was
on the horizon for um for destiny
now we know what the road map is at
least when it comes to expansions for
the next two to three years
so now it's just up to them to basically
just
tie up these totally story lines and
push us through the content
and give us as much as they possibly can
give us but i'm just excited because we
get to do this stuff all over again
and have fun and that's what destiny is
it's fun it's fun the best games i'm
playing and like you said you said it
best before i ended up is that an
attic didn't even admit this but we were
even we
dragged poor old death singer and that
spyro stars
how much fun death was it wasn't you
throwing that football to me
i'm catching you know what i said it's
fun
bro it's nothing like it man and to get
another like
addict you know better than everyone
when you get that new raid
that day one that that sense of wonder
the best cooperative
experience in my opinion in gaming on
console
i'm not a wild guy so i'm not gonna
disrespect the wild community but in my
opinion
there's nothing like even we play the
whack rages because we want to get
all the best content to prep ourselves
for beyond life
and we're having a ball throwing this
football around doing these mechanics
and it out that's destiny man it's just
nothing better but again go talk to your
slander
addict before we leave no i mean i
i got no issue with this show it's just
i got to see results like
i feel you you got you got to be
like the whole year i've been doing
public events and stuff like i got to
see better content
delivery i just got to yeah i know you
you you i'm not going with blind faith
anymore i'm just not your whole thing is
you are
anti i'm gonna i'm gonna buy this yeah
you're anti-seizing no i'm not
anti-season
i like saint 14th season okay
and i like this season because of the
the ships like i like evolving
doors like that like it's just you said
you need to sleep you tired
sorry i didn't like when they made that
that that portal and then after it was
over it just disappeared there's no
reason that like you're just gone yeah
you know it's just i got to see stuff i
literally spent 40 dollars to play rape
yeah no your whole thing is you're not
going by blind faith you want to you got
to play it you got to be excited you got
to see them do what they got to do
that's fair
all right i feel like i i like a little
man i'm with you on that trust me i
refuse i didn't get two weapons in this
stupid deal there's expansions that they
were doing because i refused to do stuff
that they wanted me to do
so trust me i feel you on that whole
that whole grind thing but the biggest
thing is
i i never look at what they're giving me
in the seasons
as the the whole
like the dinner of what destiny is like
we put so much into destiny in that
first two months
there's people like shot like god he
didn't have a lot of the stuff that
happened
years ago and there's a lot of people
like that it's just the fact that
us being hardcore gamers we a lot of us
blow through this content the fact that
cog took two weeks off work
he gonna be bored as hell in a month
let me tell you this is the part that
excites me and this is all i'm hoping
this first
thing right here beyond like campaign
when i see that word campaign that
excites me because
when i we can say whatever we want about
destiny 2 vanilla there was something
fire about doing every story mission
getting that cinematic with goal
getting that narrative like if they and
the way this is looking they giving us
mad cinematics man interactions with
people like
that's what i want kind of i know it's
selfish but i kind of want that all the
time
like i love like even forsaken right you
aldrin's doing this you're doing that
you're seeing the build
up him chasing getting tricked by riven
you know i'm saying like i
want that level of storytelling all the
time and generally it seems that only
the expansions do it
so that's why i'm confident because the
expansions have always shown
with the narrative stuff they are
usually solid now after the expansion
is over in february that's where all
bets is offered that's where i'm with
attic that has not
proven that they have can continue that
level of quality
during the middle cause they got it just
kind of hanging on but that's where i'm
at man but yeah i thought
i thought it was a good surprise good
surprise vdoc you know other than that
it was good only thing that could have
uh surpassed it if it was some random
announcement that uh microsoft bought
them or something
yeah but that's what i got man anybody
get up out of here
lord forte the dps podcast yo y'all the
half acting left man
we gotta go he wouldn't be my other half
if he wasn't
if i could have one thing on a personal
note please very yeah i'm
also just really excited because i feel
like
for well not me enough for the first
time certainly not for you guys
but for me somewhat this is kind of
going to be i think one of the
one of the first times where i mean we
have six people in here right
we are all kind of going the exact same
direction on the same platform at the
exact same time
yeah and like i am very excited to
hit the raid with everybody here oh yeah
oh yeah shout out to them for not
bringing out this update to december
that saved a lot of people on pc
yeah and you know i just got to point
out oh lord
what why haven't you like played with
other people
cause he might have done he's a loner
bro because he's on pc that's
why no but you know
i would give it back yeah i feel you
like if cat daddy gave me a shout out to
him because
i am so excited be you
addict what say like this is the team
like we're gonna do a
day one rave bro we'll be streaming it
too we're gonna stream it the lords are
gonna stream it like
there's something that the excitement
the joy with that and
i go front like y'all get busy like this
is a good team
like y'all get busy so i'm just like to
be with y'all
for day one going to deep stone crib see
what's going on with these exo's let me
get some k-lore
i'm hyped man i'm hyped yo because i
feel like we were always
we would play together but we it was
actually took a while for us to all get
together in like a raid we finally got
like our raid practice coming into this
last
at the end of the season so thanks you
know i'll text you we're doing well for
us
easy slow down slow down
all that [ __ ] that's always the that's
always the way you want to go but you
know
oh my god you're going to hear me talk a
lot of [ __ ]
and it's not going to be please stay off
your bonsai's timeline please
i'm talking [ __ ] about the i'm gonna
talk [ __ ] to the destiny community
i'm like how are you gonna let casual
destiny player like me beat you guys
stop it you've never seen a humble man
not be humble
we get ready for the world first there's
a whole other level what's up
what's up you gotta remember to take me
through at some point as well
the raid oh
look we got to wrap up this is a fun one
let's start with my boy forte dps
podcast and his amazing channel how many
subs you at now bro you're moving
i'm what 29 away from 20 what 2400.
about the past i love podcast jesus
[Music]
this is why i deal with the slander from
my co-host
shout out to him the um july 12th
was when we started the challenge where
i had to make a video every day
every day and ever since that happened i
have grown my channel by all
just over almost a thousand are you
brother proud of you i'm proud of you i
love the competition that you and attic
are doing with each other
pushing each other both you guys are
growing i love you just
check your yeah yeah that's lee hayden
co-host or dps podcast make sure you
check
it out well that's an extra view for you
guys so you should be happy
well look anytime he's over here
spending in the destiny stream is it's
good
it's good for us in the community
question is he needs to start super he
got to start putting that in color
he's gonna hate on it he does
because i noticed that he i i he he got
deep pockets but you know he you got to
make sure that he
if you're going to talk to that relative
you got to actually you got to you got
to spend that money though
unless you're doing that listen man yeah
he out of control he said i'm the
counselor he's like yo
salute man you definitely do your thing
hey wait give us the uh the date man
i mean the day thursday what time the
whole day yeah man dbs podcast damage
per second every thursday 9 p.m by
popular demand even though one person
thinks it was the most
craziest move ever he didn't want to do
it but he finally acquiesced to it so
uh shout out to everybody there um
really appreciate it we had 68 people
there last week um
we went over a whole bunch of stuff you
know the debate was on last week which
kind of
was like god damn it something's always
going on a day that we want to go live
but uh yeah man i appreciate everybody
on this podcast man you guys
all help us grow and all the shout outs
on twitter and everything so
yeah subscribe to it's going to be on
slo-mo's channel this week so
if you if you're down for it make sure
you stop by sub to his channel swim up
back slap sub demise gaming forte follow
us on twitter
we're always if you want some good
banter it happens everywhere
youtube and twitter so please follow us
there you already know that's my bros
right here
it's a little slow-mo for being messy
but it's always fun when he's in here
absolutely
and of course my man will help scream
pulled up last minute what's going on
bro we're gonna
find people finding what you got going
on man uh wilhelm scream on youtube
i think just that search actually will
help will find me now which is sort of
funny
and going into this season literally
every single channel iron lord's podcast
gaming addict gaming forte who's going
to be linked in every single thing that
i put out
because if i'm not playing with you guys
i'm not playing i appreciate it bottom
line
check out everybody else here thanks
guys for having me you already know like
i said always shout out your boss
i was like yo andy got a shout out
because he
made the connection and like i said yeah
i'm gonna say that then i'm like you fam
i'm like screaming family man i love
playing that scene with you brother you
are
yeah one thing i do want to say um
scream i'm just happy that you changed
your twitter handle from
destiny and destiny intel
[Laughter]
i wouldn't go search for you to send you
stuff one day and i was like
that's the intel why is that coming up
it did not
will him and i said oh look he actually
made it all consistent
that's my apathy on twitter
all we need to do is to tweet them
videos more man promote yourself man you
got good
if you guys are in the video i'll tweet
it
and across the palm my man sleeper
catalyst
assistant deaf singer what's going on
man
why does it have to be sleeping sleep
man
i gotta talk my talk what's going on
what's going on
you know you can find me everywhere the
same
name as you see everywhere i guess
and yeah that's about it
and that's about it and hopefully like i
said depending on the status of the raid
team he's on standby
we got a lot of even before that we got
a lot of stuff we could be playing in
destiny def singer is definitely
an active member of the clan always
supports the lord it's always fun to
have him on stream
especially xbox streams he's hilarious
but
salute to you bro yeah i'm excited i
didn't like you snickering when osiris
got slapped
don't ever do that again on stream
i was so disgusted i was like why that
had to happen with def cigarettes i mean
why
because i know me and you always have on
titan warlock battles
so i'm like oh i'm never going to hear
the end of this i'm never going to
it wouldn't be you if you didn't send me
that gift of osiris getting slapped so i
got to deal with that i understand i
gotta wait
slapped and saved by a hunter i don't
like how he got slapped at the gunfire
on his head
you know guardian people dropped a gun
that's what i'm saying
all right like but with saved a shout
out to ogen i'm such an older fan boy
because i won i was pulling for him to
be the vanguard hunters didn't like that
they thought it was going to be some
other van gogh i'm telling you man oh
dream come on that's your
choice honestly exactly you already know
but he is a hunter
and a hunter saying bro your king oh
this is just good
i don't want to talk about this y'all
getting out of control anyway
lord attic sleepy addict but
a little happier as as the trailer went
on i thought what's going on man
pretty good about to uh go get something
to eat so uh let's let's let's end this
you already know who i am lord cognition
shout out to y'all for coming through
about 130
just for destiny on the last minute
stream y'all respect i really appreciate
it man
everybody get ready by uh console
brothers you already know what it is
november 10th
y'all gonna be dealing with 30 friends
but december 8th y'all know what time it
is for that patch
and last word will be i'll give you our
preview last word this friday
7 p.m eastern we got a big one y'all
make sure to check it out
rick cackington the third you already
know who he is
rick cackas is gonna be in the building
man so check us out on
our last word of 7 p.m it's going to be
on twitch he bounces his channel first
and then you already know the archives
will go up
and then sunday we'll have a special
guest but i can't spoil that just yet
you know what i'm saying but that'll be
sunny but look everybody enjoy get y'all
dusty get your grind on
and i'ma talk to y'all